one of the biggest pushes I got was it
eight years old I was a musician I
wanted to get an electric guitar and I
asked my dad and his response to an
eight-year-old was great get a [__]
job welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders I am with
Eric huberman the CEO and founder who
launched Hawk media in 2014 now valued
at over 100 million dollars talked media
is the fastest growing marketing
consultancy agency in the United States
prior to its launch Eric successfully
founded grew and sold two e-commerce
companies by the age of 26. he has since
continued to strategically expand his
business portfolio inclusive of a
handful of company Acquisitions Hawk
Ventures which raised 25 million dollars
in a second fund and most recently hogzi
an agency offering Brands the tools
needed to tap into Generation Z as a
serial entrepreneur and marketing expert
Eric has been recognized by his industry
peers through honors and awards
including Forbes Magazine's 30 under 30
csq's 40 under 40 and Inc magazine's top
25 marketing influencers
I'm really excited to to have you here
and spend these 20 minutes getting to
know you your your story your
entrepreneurial story Hawk media now
also event with a venture arm and I'm
excited to unfold a little bit about you
know the the foundation for it what it
represents today how you're continuing
to grow it and position it as a
sustainable business and something that
you are personally obviously very proud
of and it's part of your life so so Eric
tell me first a little bit about
yourself you know a little bit of
background and you know you as an
entrepreneur what does that mean to you
yeah you know like me as an entrepreneur
my grandfather was an entrepreneur my
dad was an entrepreneur so like I grew
up just thinking that's what you did
like that you could go get a job to
learn something and people could work
for other people but that it was always
an option and I just assumed that
because that's what I came from like
that's what I do is run a business and I
grew up wanting a position but quickly
learned that uh understanding business
was a good thing for musicians it's a
Well longer story but it was a cool
lesson and so I just always had an
interest in like from six years old I
was trying to make money my dad did a
good job of like he basically taught me
the idea of saving up to get the next
dollar bill meaning like I'm gonna save
all my money so I can afford a five
dollar bill then I'm Gonna Save More so
I can afford a ten dollar bill and a 20
then a 50 then 100 and it was like this
goal for me that it was just intrinsic
value of making money and
um something sap you know really stuck
with me that at a young age that then I
was always looking for ways to make
money and build things and I think one
of the biggest pushes I got was it eight
years old I was a musician I wanted to
get an electric guitar and I asked my
dad and his response to an
eight-year-old was great get a [__]
job
okay you know that's an interesting
response
yeah it is but the funny thing is like I
didn't take it like every adult would
hear it which is like are you nuts what
did you just say that to an
eight-year-old as an eight-year-old I
was like all right I'll go get a job
like I didn't know any different my dad
tells me to get a job I'm gonna go
figure it out so I started selling
lemonade I sold flowers and then I fell
into buying and selling beanie babies
when I was at the peak basically and or
actually before the peak so I got into
it and as an eight-year-old I ended up
making a few thousand bucks buying and
selling beanie babies and sold them on
you know trade shows and blah blah and
like figure that business out of like
what I thought what people would like
and how I could hype up the Collectibles
and make that money so I bought my
guitar I bought a BMX bike and I saved
some money for a guitar or a car later
on that's a few thousand sitting in my
bank account and this was how it started
it's like I that was like making money
in order to afford something but it also
made me realize that I kind of like the
wheeling and dealing and it got me over
any kind of inhibitions about like doing
deals and so from that point on there
was always something thing I was trying
to do some business I was trying to
start and I always just had a
fascination with it Without Really
consciously saying I'm going to be an
entrepreneur like up until I was
really 17 I didn't think of myself as
pursuing like owning a business I like I
tried to start little things but I was
always like I tried to start an online
music company uh to like buy and sell or
sell music equipment this is like 98 I
think 19 wow because I just thought that
it'd be fun to work in that field and
also I would get good retail deals with
all the music equipment companies that
then I could buy my stuff cheaper so
that's how I was talking about this but
then
um going through high school I realized
I wasn't going to be a musician when I
got older I wasn't that good and so I
pivoted to unwilling to be in the music
business and then around 17 was when I
went I don't really need to go to music
business I can just be in business and
enjoy playing music and that's when I
started looking at starting other
businesses I started learning from my my
dad was in real estate and in the waste
business I'd actually went who worked
with one of his senior Executives on
that handled all the management of the
properties to learn about how they how
they managed money how they looked at
properties how they able to returns and
that kind of thing and so that helped
and then I went to college and did a
whole bunch of different things and then
came out in 2008 went into real estate
that grown an affinity for it I started
a week before women Brothers collapsed
decided that wasn't probably going to be
my future I made 350 dollars my first
year out of college and so that's when I
started building online companies and
went off that way and built three sold
wow and that brings us to about nine
years ago when I started building Hawk
media
the world was media how does that how
did that come about for you
yeah I mean it started with me making
fun of marketing majors in high school
or sorry in college I'm like what do you
do like Drop pictures like never took it
seriously but then I uh
I built my own online companies and
realized that like operationally they
were always pretty easy to run I ran a
music company then a t-shirt
subscription site then a women's active
or brand and like making t-shirts or
making Women's Active or wasn't that
difficult there was a very clear
solution to it but the opportunity cost
in marketing of doing it right or wrong
is insane if you do a really good job
the world's your oyster if you miss like
and it's a completely siding scale that
never ends so I be owning these
businesses I paid a lot of attention to
marketing and so when I sold the last
one and had success in it I started
helping other people figure this stuff
out because I realized how hard it was
and through doing that I uh
through helping them I realized oh wow
this whole ecosystem is broken most
agencies suck a few that are good are
really hard to work with it's impossible
to find good talent in-house like
there's got to be a better way so I
built a small little SWAT team for my
companies that I was advising for each
with their own expertise like a Facebook
marketer an email marketer web designer
and just said hey have a card month to
month we're going to be the best at what
we do but really easy to work with and
that's literally been the you know sort
of mission sense is we articulate it as
accessibility to Great marketing again
let's be the best at what we do but
really easy to work with Nimble flexible
Innovative Etc so
that's that's what we how we built and
so fast forward it's been eight and a
half years we're 200 and something
full-time people run marketing wow
actively 600 rents right now manage
about wow billion dollars in advertising
spend uh we have a 50 million dollar
Venture fund we're on our second fund we
have our financing arm that's doing tens
of millions of dollars of working
capital loans for our clients and we
recently six weeks ago launched our AI
tool that within six weeks we have two
thousand paid users and it's just Off to
the Races so built a whole ecosystem
around this that now it's been yeah
really fun really powerful and it's all
bootstrapped we haven't raised any money
that's just unbelievable okay so I have
to I have to you know go back as an
entrepreneur and and figure out this
obviously you know it's not just you're
starting you know multiple companies and
then in the midi company but it sounds
like within this Media Company you're
also continuing to start newer companies
within this company and continue to grow
into different regions you know tell me
a little bit about this mindset you know
this is it's not it's not trivial what
What's Happening Here
I saw a chart a long time ago that
always stuck with me which is you know
Revenue curves I think it might be
backwards here but they kind of go up
Steep and then they flatten out so it
lines of business individual businesses
this is how the revenue usually works
you can't grow this whole hockey stick
thing happens maybe in the first couple
years but then it kind of goes like this
and then you know levels out levels out
levels out and you can't on an
individual business line see this all
the you know forever and so someone I
forgot and I learned that but someone
taught me that and what the idea of
wanting a great if you want an overall
organization to continue to grow
exponentially you have to stack those so
as they Trail off you add a new line of
business and that shot shoots up and
then Trails off and that shoots up and
then Trails off and so you keep stacking
Innovation give Apple like Apple started
with you know desktop computers but
iPhone has been that Innovation for now
and the next thing I don't know is cars
whatever it is they're going to watch
advertising Etc you have to as a
business keep adding revenue streams
that have a chance for hyper growth both
because your core business the chances
of it continuing hyper growth forever is
Slim to not it doesn't happen you know
and so same reason big businesses make
Acquisitions of smaller businesses is if
you take Coca-Cola Coca-Cola like the
product is not going to have hyper
growth they've distributed it all around
the world they're it's done so for them
to grow they grab smaller businesses get
them into their distribution and boom
you now have twice as much product on
that shelf twice as much revenue so same
thing with us
it goes with just Individual Services so
like right now just being transparent
we're talking about adding connected TV
to our services we uh we Sunset of their
production team and we're going to grow
a new one and rebuild our production
capabilities we are looking at several
uh and so in even just the service
offerings well there are other things
that our clients want that we could be
offering that we can do well so it
doesn't hurt us but it just helps and we
can be a more focused and that's how we
built out most of our services you know
like
we didn't have affiliate marketing we
started with a partner we started
offering affiliate marketing with this
partner and all of a sudden we became
most of their business and it was
working really well and we bought that
agency and now we have a huge affiliate
team so it's things like that that we're
always looking on top of that it's just
by Nature fun to look at okay what else
could I be doing with this platform so
what the Venture fund really came first
in that stack it was like oh we have all
these companies we have full data on we
know how they're working we have we get
access to every deal we could ever want
maybe we should start Angel Investing
and my first Angel investment became a
multi-billion dollar company in a few
years and I was one of their First
Investors I was like [__] like I mean I
knew they were going to be successful
that it ended up being complete outlier
but it also encouraged me to keep going
after seven deals we had an average 11x
return and I was like that's absurdly
powerful we should do more of this but I
can't afford to just do it myself we
raise the fund that's one
same thing happened with working capital
we had tons of clients that we'd grow
really fast and the problem with Hyper
growth is you end up a lot of times cash
constrained because you can't keep up
well if we're doubling let's say we're
making you 10 times your money on your
advertising but you don't have enough
cash to keep going what if I gave you a
seven percent loan
well I'm doubling your money or sorry
10x in your money here's seven percent
like God forbid seven percent when
you're already 10x in your money fine
sure and so we're obviously fine
indicate loans get that done and now we
can grow companies even faster and then
the tool the AI tool was really a
function of what do I think is going to
disrupt the marketing industry overall
and it was the idea of somewhere
someone's going to build something that
can tap in all your marketing channels
monitor them in real time Benchmark you
against your industry and then provide
Insight on where you need to actually be
focusing on your marketing efforts and
take away that force from the trees
problem and then eventually when AI gets
the point it'll actually just start
making fixes itself so it's like okay
but I have to start from square one I
have to build the monitoring then the
benchmarking then the insights then the
AI so we started building that and I
started with the data piece seven years
ago finally got the platform piece we
acquired a software company in February
implemented the two and now we have the
benchmarking tool and hence why it grew
so fast it's like every marketer needs
this we made it you know cost effective
and here we are so these are all things
that it's like we need this this is
where the industry is going and let's
keep you know keep up with that
where's all this energy coming from I
mean I'm just feeling the the crazy
entrepreneurial energy that you're
presenting here as you're talking about
the different adventures and I and I and
I I'm noticing it because I I can see
you can see myself in a lot of this one
where is all this coming from
I learned a lot about it this year so
it's fun fun timing because I haven't
talked about this so like the beginning
of this year we dealt with a ton of
headwinds in the business and I lost a
lot of that energy like we had internal
people really screwing up stuff you know
with some lying going on some really
almost criminal stuff fapping in the
business that hurt us for a few months
and all that energy went away and so the
truth is that energy comes from positive
reinforcement that energy comes from I
work my ass off and everything that I
put into this business I get out that I
see the success I see the growth I see
the progress I see that when we put it
when I put my mind to something it works
and it just makes me want to do more of
it because if I spend a week in New York
City grinding and meeting people and
working I Come Away with a ton of you
know new customers and new progress and
new ideas that feedback cycle makes it
really easy to keep going so like I
don't blame the lack of it with some
people that don't get that same outcome
like if you're not in a job that has a
lot of upside to working harder yeah I
understand why you want to work that
hard and so that to me is like a big
part it's like and I'm not saying just
monetarily like making money is great
but thankfully I'm past the point of
needing to like pay my bills it's more
about like I see the growth I see the
success of our clients I see like this
thing that we're growing and that
continues to be right to onboard you
know bigger and bigger companies smart
people like one of the biggest rewarding
things is to spend years building this
tool call some of the biggest marketers
in the world and biggest private Equity
Funds in the world have them vet it and
vet the data and go this is incredible
like I as much as I'm confident I was
still like really
so that's where you get I get the energy
is once you do it and you put all that
work in and you get that feedback it's
like okay awesome let's keep going
so is it about the media Market is about
the you know specific monitor is it
about the enteral journey for you I mean
if you had to distill sort of what makes
entrepreneur yeah
yeah hands down I like marketing the
reason I'm in marketing is because it
turns out I have a knack for it so like
the combinations of what you're good at
and what you like to do is really
important but you know if it was
building it like I could be in private
Equity my wife's in it so I have a lot
of like now I have a lot of insight into
it I'm like this is a fun business like
I love the idea of buying companies
helping grow on blah blah blah like
that's great too I could be in SAS I
have a SAS business now I like the idea
of this but my focus is I love growing
things and so my focus would always be
growth which marketing goes hand in hand
with that I also like I run our sales
team you know like I I'm very Hands-On
with sales with Partnerships with
Channel Partnerships with client success
like I love that aspect of it so it's
not just marketing it's just marketing
is a big part of it
right and so if you're looking at your
own your own Journey sort of your vision
for yourself do you reduce yourself ever
not being an entrepreneur I mean is that
something that you're even thinking
about it just uh
what is this for you there might be I
think there might come a point it's
something point where the investing side
will start to overtake but I think I'll
like someone made a point to me the
other day because I was like I like
operating I like running businesses and
they said yeah but as an investor I can
invest and you know be Hands-On with the
company but then go home and go to sleep
at night and it's like I've been running
this yeah I've been running businesses
for a long time uh not that long but
long enough that it's like yeah I think
you know at a later point in my life
where the energy is not as easy to come
by I could see you know my 50s 60s 70s
whatever that is I doubt that I'm going
to want to be grinding every day but uh
but that also could look different that
could look like me chairman of my own
company and have a CEO because there's a
lot of ways to get there but uh but yeah
wanting to not like wake up every
morning and hit the ground running
but I don't know and so if you're
looking at him yeah
if you're looking at the the different
you know entrepreneurial Journeys that
you've had until now you're trying to
sort of clean the picture and draw
connect the dot between these these
points and and given what we just talked
about your you know that this idea of
what of what entrepreneurship means to
you how do you how do you see you know
what what are different things that
you've observed that you learned about
yourself that are that aren't
necessarily trivial
yeah
um I've learned that the the probably
the toughest lesson I've learned is as
an entrepreneur this is a cliche but no
one really comprehends it and that's my
view of it because I've heard it 100
times too like No One's Gonna care as
much as you do as a business owner
entrepreneur of course that's a given of
course No One's Gonna care as much as
you do that being said if the company
struggles or fails
as an employee your worst case scenario
is you got to go get another job and
generally given outside of like the
depth of a recession if you're a
talented person you're probably going to
get a job so that is the worst case
scenario is I have to go find a new job
for an entrepreneur you lose everything
it's your baby it's your livelihood and
it's not like you don't just get get a
new job you never had a job you had a
business so it's such a different level
of pressure to keep it going that is
when you think about it that way it's
obvious that as an entrepreneur you're
always going to have to grind more to
keep your business going yes you can put
people in great places and you can put
have great Executives that are smart and
hard working but at the end of the day
when push comes to shove if the
executive doesn't see their upside
sticking with you outweighs just joining
a different company and using your
company on their resume they're gonna
start looking and that's and that's not
a bad thing I don't think that that's
there to blame or that's bad people it's
just human nature and like people need
to look out for what's best for them so
that has been one of the tougher or but
also most important realizations is that
doesn't mean like
again that people are bad it's just like
understand that like the dream of like
having a team of people that just run
your business for you that I hear about
this like you know Paradise situation
from entrepreneurs that doesn't exist
and that's okay because when you come to
terms with that you know like it is your
job to run your business it is your job
to drive and that doesn't go away so
just be aware on that that has been an
important lesson for me
let that West I love that almost almost
crushed my business and thankfully I
learned it fast enough
I love that
um it's a lot of responsibility that
you're taking and so it's a big big toll
it's a big decision that you're making
and it sounds sort of like a once you're
committing to that decision you have to
understand you know what you're really
committing to
once your your downside as an
entrepreneur is a lot higher than the
downside of an individual point assuming
you're I mean you can just go get a job
too I guess but even winding down a
business is expensive so yeah keeping
keeping your eye on everything and
making sure you're the one driving
things is generally how you're gonna
have to run a business
completely Eric I really want to thank
you for coming on and sharing these uh
20 minutes with me it sounds like an
awesome Journey that you've added so
it's like hey sort of you know really do
embody just the true Spirit of what
entrepreneurship is about and I can
relate to that quite a bit and so I
really thank you for coming here and
enjoy your time in New York and uh and
and really congrats on all the amazing
milestones and achievements it's a
really really phenomenal thank you
yeah no thank you for having me
[Music]